[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum here with Ryan Tellez
busy week man
yeah we've been doing it we have the
talkville episodes we had uh
you know ads and stuff like that and uh
you know it's just uh intros outros yeah
you know it's a lot of stuff it's good I
just had we just had a guest that just
left yeah Nestor carbonel who I love
from Lost and Pates Motel what a great
guy he'll be on uh down the line so you
want to listen to that what a great
story you know but it's uh parents
immigrating from Cuba it's a good one
I'm looking forward to that yeah he was
he was special you know I did this thing
I haven't talked about it a lot but I
will but um this is unbelievable it's uh
it's called prenuvo it's this uh
body scan it's it it you it's like an
MRI but there's no radiation it's not
harmful or anything at all but you do
this body scan complete body scan and it
will detect so many things that could be
going wrong that you aren't even aware
of you know because you go and they're
by the way they're not giving me any
money I just think this is amazing and I
did a scan but um you know they detect
stage one cancers all of them except
leukemia so if you had a mass it would
show it and you could treat it so much
earlier than you would have if you
didn't
you know it's just pretty amazing but uh
I posted something on Instagram on
stories I haven't posted on Instagram
but I'm gonna post it once my results
come back there was my results come back
in a week but it's I I recommend
everybody doing this I think this is
going to be part of the norm this is uh
pretty incredible to be able to see if
there's things going on and it's not
just cancers it's other things
abnormalities or whatever but uh if you
want to try this scan it's in selected
cities
um you know
uh use my code for uh 300 off it's
pronuvo.com Michael
p-r-e-n-u-v-o.com slash Michael it's
It's Gonna Save Many Lives Many Lives
they see it all the time or they see a
stage one cancer or something and
um I was just curious I was like you
know I want to kind of jump on that
stuff
uh the health stuff so I got the scan
and I was nervous and when I went in it
was really cool it's laid back I was in
and out in like an hour and
um I watched Seinfeld during my scan and
it was cool
so again what's the deal with this game
what's the deal with my body someone
help me scan me I want to know hey
Jerry all right prenuvo.com p r e n u v
o.com slash Michael
um what else we got um
lots of good stuff going on
um we were just at a con Tom and I
um we were in Vegas and then we were in
Dallas but we've got these new art
pieces on the taco podcast website
talkfillpodcast.com
and it's uh their original pieces of art
we hired this artist and she made only
55 prints and we're selling those
autographed a lot of cool stuff there
and on the inside of you online store we
got ship Keys lexmus scripts and tons of
inside of you cool mercs to support the
podcast and last but not least of course
um join patreon patreon uh is the reason
why this podcast and talk feel are
surviving and that's the honest to God
truth is because patrons who give
something to the show listening is
enough but if you want to give something
great
um go to
patreon.com inside of you and also
the band sunspin our album just came out
you can stream it for free everywhere or
you can get merch and CDs and stuff at
sunspin.com that's it our handles for
inside of you Ryan uh inside of you pod
on Twitter outside of your podcast
Instagram and Facebook that is correct
we love and support love the support and
write a review it helps the podcast All
That Jazz
um this next guest is someone I just
adore uh you know I had this I was at a
con and I met him and then he was giving
me a massage because I had a big knot
knit
um
you know this guy from so much he's he's
a great director he's a great actor
it was just funny very he was very
relaxed in the studio he came in here
and just put his feet up and just kind
of went along you know he just is is who
he is and I love that I had so much fun
with him
um
you know from Star Trek and the movies
and the you know he's directing episodes
he's working on the new Picard they've
got a reunion thing coming up and you
got to check that out that's why we're
airing this because it's about to happen
um so you want to listen to this and
find out the inside scoop on a lot of
these actors but uh yeah without further
Ado let's just do it let's get inside of
Jonathan Frakes it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience I take my shoes off yeah
I could take his shoes off what about my
pants you know well you know oh I don't
mind but you know what's funny is Kevin
Nealon wants he just lied down and it
was like you know just put his hands
behind his back do you listen to
smartless
um I've listened to an episode or two
it's great they tested Dana Carvey
yesterday and I I walked the dog
listened to it I was roaring in the
street and people looked at me like I
was insane really Carvey is he was on
fire he did all of his people all of his
Impressions he did church lady to George
Bush and then he did himself
interviewing different characters that
he it was really brilliant you know
what's funny is when I was a kid my
parents I was they always made me
babysit my brother I never I never went
to a high school dance I never I never
left the house they just kept me
trapping that's why you got me here yeah
I would look around you're comfortable
like this Look Away
um and I remember I would watch SNL
and I had nothing better to do so I'd
memorize all the sketches and the voices
and they'd come home and I'd go which
era is this uh this is the 80s
so it was like it was the same thing so
I was like hello again it's the church
lady and this is church chat wow that's
the Kevin Nealon era too no Kevin Neil
and era so that's what I really grew up
with and then into the Sandler phase
obviously but um yeah I but I always
would do Impressions and stuff just to
get attention and get people to go oh
you know and that's that's kind of like
you like attention don't you I'm a bit
of attention [__] yeah I mean I've
never got attention as a kid
now you hear that a lot and sometimes
you know people need attention do you
feel like you got a lot of attention you
have attention growing up yeah you did
yeah a lot of actors didn't though am I
all I'm actually my parents my father
especially was very happy to have me be
an actor as opposed to a lot of actors
why is that he was a film buff he loved
John Ford and he leads to make me watch
movies and he was a teacher and he he
his thing was you got to do something
that you really
love Yeah but wasn't he also was it hard
because he was a a book critic for the
New York Times so if you did a project
weren't you going oh my God he's gonna
Hammer me he's going to look at it a
certain way the whole thing about him we
could do him should we start on Jim Dr
James R Frakes let's do it
I tell a great story I think about when
he died uh years ago
and I inherited his uh the books that he
had taught of his teaching editions of
all Hemingway Faulkner Joyce
Henry James you know the Contemporary
guys and all that [__] he was um
so he was very loved teacher and uh
would go back and reread his novels
before he taught him so he one time in
high school after having read uh
um something I said I'm ready to read
Ulysses Joy says Ulysses
portrait of an Artist as a Young Man
which you have to read when you're in
high school right so he said uh Jonathan
you're really not ready for Ulysses you
can't handle Ulysses
okay Dad fine so he's dead I'm now
probably 60 and my little librarian
Maine which looks like this room in the
pull-up and I'm getting very sentimental
because I got a chair that was his chair
that when he was given this special
chair and it's got this is Lehigh
University in the back and I'm sitting
in Dad's chair and I take you the
dog-eared Ulysses out of the thing that
I said I thought this would be a great
moment I'll have a moment with my dead
Dad we're hoping I'd do about two
paragraphs
that I [__] lost completely out of my
Realm and I said yeah you're right you
can't handle you listening I'm 62 years
old I put the [__] book back I
haven't taken it down since she never
read you listening I still I'm not ready
I can't handle your listings obviously
my dad was right you can't handle
Ulysses either
what you never read your list no no yes
I'm not gonna lie I read some Nietzsche
and I was lost but I know
Nietzsche is even easier to understand
yeah probably I don't know is that
Harrison Ford next to you that is
Harrison Ford that's uh Raiders of the
Lost Ark you ever see that movie oh I
watched uh
the Raiders I was just I just finished I
just finished a Hallmark Christmas movie
really there's some tea there you didn't
know that did you no I didn't but I hear
a lot of people are doing those now I
noticed a lot of actors you know they
get paid well I guess and they it's it's
a great kick and picardo is on it
picardo had a day on it I thought
somebody had a nice evening with him but
I I get home because we're on two to two
because the uh Biltmore Hotel it was a
Vanderbilt builtmore Hotel the stories
at Christmas a Biltmore Christmas but
they stayed open during the day so we
worked from two to two so you get back
to the hotel and on the movie channel
was that Raiders of the Lost Ark Raiders
Jurassic Park the original Jurassic Park
so about three o'clock in the morning
where you're winding down there was
something to watch what were you
first of all a Hallmark movie is it just
something that you can easily just walk
through yeah well I still worry about
more than ever worry about holding the
lines
I was playing the um
sort of the caretaker or the caretaker
of the uh Biltmore Estate so I was doing
the tour so I had [__] pages of
chatter about who this is who this
mythical character is and it's it throws
back to a 1940s movie that was shot at
the hotel and so I had a lot of setting
up Pages why do you accept something
like that do you stress with it money
well why would you right but but let me
ask you I mean do you when you read
something you're like hoping do you now
hope I don't have a lot but I don't have
a lot oh yeah I hope his face is only
because it's probably I mean when you
look at all these like how long does it
take you to learn maybe a couple pages
of dialogue I can it takes me ages my
wife as you know I'm married to Judy
Francis and I just sent her off to work
and she literally
um she's doing eight shows in five days
this week and she does 30 pages of
dialogue at night some nights and she
will look at him for she's been doing it
for 45 years she'll look at the dialogue
and if she has a lot of dialogue maybe
40 minutes
what wait a minute and then she gives me
I said okay let me see if I have that
and she gives me the script
and she [__] kills it day after day
after day after day after day how
intimidating is that well it's again
it's because she's so good at it that
only you know expands my paranoia about
it but she also has a muscle that very
few people have she's been done since
she was 13. that's a rarity a lot of you
are you good with lines you know I think
it was better when I was younger but
like now it definitely scares me if
someone says hey they want you for this
you're gonna shoot Monday and it's a
Friday and that's right you got to make
sure you read it I didn't read the oh
yeah I just took the job
and then where you once you accepted it
you're like oh [__] well I knew the
director I worked with John punch who
was the director he used to actually was
on Star Trek and Puch said you want to
come do this job I don't know what you'd
make but you make some money picardo's
gonna be in it we'll fly into North
Carolina if you will do it try to knock
all your stuff off in a week
so why wouldn't I say yes don't you say
yes to when a director asks you to do a
job no really not unless I really want
to do it wow you are different you don't
need the money well it's not that I mean
you you you don't need the money but
don't you love to work
no and I'll get to the pointers here you
like this
um you you can fulfill you have enough
hobbies that you don't have to be that's
weird too because uh I talk about this
ad nauseam but like I let's talk about
this ad nauseam pretty much yeah I I
love acting I
I did it in high school I did it through
college I did theater I did Off Broadway
stuff like you did and you know I had
that bug but I think part of me I'll
just be honest was like I want to be on
TV I want to be in the movies I want to
be seen I want to be and even though I
studied hard and worked hard and really
took it seriously so when you got it
there was there was an element of fun
for me like it was like a fun thing and
then
but the work I think a lot of people
don't realize they think it's just easy
and fun all the time they all think it's
funny until they come to visit you and
then they say wait a minute you're
working for 12 hours why are you doing
regular days why are you doing the same
[__] scene for six hours and so look
it's not that I don't want to act it's
that if I'm gonna do something it's
Gotta for now it's just gotta be
something that I'm like oh this this
will be great this is with a great
director or this is this could this
could do that's what I'm saying if a
director that you like calls you and
offers you yeah like that's what I meant
that's okay it's called not any director
but yeah no no but a director that you
know in life yeah like let's say yeah
let's say I'd call you
because I used to be a nice little
director I mean you you're a big
director now you direct a lot I mean
we've been talking but I want to talk
about like you talk about your dad and I
I could see when you're telling that
story how you remember it's so vivid and
I could just see the room you're in and
yeah and just well he was he meant a lot
to you he was great well your mother and
father both really good parents maybe
um my dad was a uh
uh eccentric
and didn't like to travel
his traveling was going on the portrait
of a cigarette you know my mom wanted to
go to England and Ireland and all you
know so there was that
he worked his ass off
she took care of us he was diabetic so
she made sure he got fed at all the
right times
he um
he was the Muse to a lot of I grew up in
Bethlehem Pennsylvania and we lived it
was you know half of us uh
half of a house and we were you know
steel Talent
and my dad we were a weird family
because we were he was an English
Professor we weren't Steel Workers we
looked next door to a rabbi who used to
paint the rocks and it was a really
eclectic weird neighborhood but the kids
I grew up with who became songwriters
and musicians and Poets would come to
our house because we had modern art on
the wall it was weird but my dad was
like a mentor to some of these kids who
are my oldest friends one of whom I just
visited last week and uh
he would he would give them wilka or
whatever he give them some poetry to
read or he'd talk about he was so
he was such a loving gentle sweet ironic
funny
um
kind of uh sarcastic
was he affectionate
yeah but not not would he give you a hug
absolutely I love you I'm proud of you
absolutely there you go yeah all of the
above see that's beautiful all of the
above
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
when you're at your best you can do
great things but sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up in the way
you want to
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you
and who couldn't use a few better coping
skills to be able to handle all of
life's curveballs look if you're
thinking of giving you therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge better
help can help you be the best you
possible try it today if you want to
live a more empowered life therapy can
get you there visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get ten percent off your
first month that's better help
help.com slash inside this podcast is
brought to you by Dove men plus care
guys do you get distracted during the
day thinking about your underarm
sweating or itching or emitting an odor
oh
do those thoughts keep you from showing
care when it counts new and improved
Dove men plus care antiperspirant with
72 hours sweat and odor protection and
one quarter moisturizing cream helps you
forget about your underarms so you can
be present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant wherever personal
care products are sold inside you is
brought to you by rocket money you want
to listen to this because you're going
to save money absolutely and I don't
know how everybody is in doing this
thing but you know those Ryan you know
those stupid things that say oh it's
free for 30 days yeah and then they
start the subscription that's how they
get you but they always get me well I
can't it says your subscription will be
canceled after 30 days it doesn't they
get you and you find out sometimes
months later and you can't do crap about
it as Farley would say you can't new
Jack Squat
and it sucks and thank God for Rocket
money all right I mean do you know how
much your subscriptions cost most of us
think they spend around 80 bucks a month
on subscriptions when the actual total
is closer to 200.
if you don't know exactly how much
you're spending every month you need
rocket money
rocket money formerly known as true
built is a personal finance app that
finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place
eighty percent of people have
subscriptions they forget about you know
the streaming ones you want to see that
one freaking show Ryan I just want to
see that one show one whatever it is
that I never even heard of this
streaming platform so you have to get it
and then you pay for it for eight months
yep
Crooks rocket money is protecting you
from Crooks
uh the average person has 12 around 12
paid subscriptions okay they have those
think about think about that if you
think you're only subscribed to a
handful of services you might want to
double check with rocket money you can
quickly identify and cancel all of your
unwanted subscriptions
all right look guys it's easy stop
throwing away your money cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com slash inside
that's rocketmoney.com inside
that's a great thing and and was he the
kind of father that would ever like
question something you did like hey you
sure you want to do this yeah you ready
for this
are you sure you want to act I'll share
this with you because I feel comfortable
all right I had just moved to New York
and uh so I was
I guess just out of college and my mom
comes because I lived an hour and a half
from New York where I grew up an hour
and a half from New York so I'm in New
York my mom comes to visit
and you know this is in the 70s so you
got your little portfolio with your
eight by tens and between I was working
as a moving person for the walk-up King
and his trustworthy Step Brothers which
was the worst [__] gig in the world
and then go into auditions and anyway my
mom comes to visit and because she's
there I'm at a cab and we're going to
dinner or something because you know you
take a Subway if your mom's not in town
right and I stopped by the uh the pot
dealer to get my little nickel bag of
pot right
and she said what is that I said oh
that's you know that's marijuana just so
I put it in my little acting bag and we
go on apparently when she went home and
told my dad she just she was so freaked
out so freaky and she didn't let you on
to no she did I could tell but she was
trying to be cool she was desperately
trying but my dad when I saw him the
next time I went home he held my face
like this and he said Jonathan
Jonathan
lie to her
[Laughter]
hey
great father but it's kind of honest
father right right you thought he was
going to say what I was waiting for
don't do this don't know what he said
lie to her this is advice God were you
tight with your like you got a you have
a brother brother yeah he was awesome he
was he was the cute one in the family
really yeah I'll tell you one more
pretty good about my dad beat her before
he also when he was talking about uh
giving the birds into bees talk about
using a condom and how you have to
respect women and all the you know all
the right things on this sex talk and he
finished the talk and we had to go
upstairs and get to the bedrooms and he
went up the stairs he stopped in the
landing he'd looked back and he said and
don't forget
sex is beautiful and he left and went
upstairs how old is he at this point
he's dead oh no at this point but not
now when he said this to you he's dead
well I was a kid you know I was whatever
you are 13. so what was he in his 40. I
remember a stupid story as my friend
Emil Camacho he was at his dinner table
and his brother Jose his older brother
got a woman pregnant and the table was
really quiet and uh Mr Camacho was a
very you know soft-spoke and didn't say
many things like when I call I go he go
hello and I go is Emil there no he
Miller's not here hang up right you know
so he's at the table and terrible uh
Filipino accent but I could say it
because you know that was Filipino I
don't know what it was but my stepmom's
Filipino my my childhood best friend I'm
just saying I'm I'm covering my ass yeah
I love Filipinos you're racist my racist
ass and I remember he says I was sitting
there and I was drinking my eating my
soup and my father goes
you could have sex with a girl but don't
get them pregnant like your brother
and he spit out his soup and that was it
but it's like hey you know uh yeah
that's the same talk but kind of in a
different but in front of everyone yeah
in front of everyone in front of
everyone
um when did you know you had like this
like love for acting like this is this
is what I want to do
it changed I I did like you did I direct
I acted in high school acted in junior
high school
I was always very popular
I was sort of popular because I was in
so many things I was in the band and I
was in the Glee Club I was in the drama
club no Sports I was on the track team I
was really bad on the basketball team I
was so bad in the basketball team I
didn't even start and then I was sort of
moved out by high school so I was
I did track in cross-country which
they're not really Sports in high school
as you probably know yeah wow I was in
the band right in the marching band
you're in the band you played trombone
play Trombone from the get-go trombone
was the instrument you chose well here's
how I chose I was in fourth grade at
Jefferson Elementary School in Bethlehem
PA and in the public school at this time
again this is now the 60s
the school district or the school gets a
certain allotment of instruments and
fourth grades where music starts so
I think there was one trauma and Two
Trumpets to Clarence you know whatever
the [__] it was and
they said Frank's stand up okay you got
the longest arms you get the trombone
you get that and you get the flute and
you get the clay so that's just like
that bam trombone
and you loved it I did love it well it
was absurd you know I like the Absurd
it's really an absurd instrument it is
that's a it's a cool instrument and I
didn't even know this you would know
this he was on the album Fisher's album
hoist it all happened across the street
from where I live from he lived you
lived across this we won't give the
address but you lived across the street
in the house supposedly Jimi Hendrix
lived in yes and you play Trombone I
lived next to Paul Fox who produced
among others the late great Paul Fox REM
and Bjork and Jacob Dillon and he was he
was wonderful
and
the guys from
fish who he also produced obviously came
to his house and hung out and the
mailbox at that house across the street
from you used to be my mailbox was a cow
you ever seen those cows and it was
dented because so many people had hit it
as I'm sure this whole drive this whole
yeah it happens it happens a lot it's
sort of the Cal version of that of the
largemouth bass mailbox which you see
out in the country right yeah yeah and
this was dented to [__] and so it was a
landmark because that's when you knew
when we got to my house or to Paul's
house
so
they knew I played trombone because they
watched Star Trek and they were big fans
of the show and all that stuff Trey
Anastasia's there yes from fish and John
Fishman who I still know and they are
there with you they're there with me and
they ask Paul to ask me to play Trombone
on their album they're working on on
Saturday in a studio out in did they
know you were good they didn't that's
the story
so I'm invited out and I'm so psyched as
you can well imagine
I get in the studio they put the chart
up on the music stand it is beyond my
capability because I am only good or was
at that point only good now I really
have no lip at all but the chart was too
high it was too fast it was it was
completely yeah and I attempted it
beat so I played what I thought you know
and he said okay let's start again and
we and it was we became clear really
fast to me but they were being very
patient the engineer was being patient
we try and try it became very clear that
it was not it was not going to work but
so they ended up hiring the trombone
player from Tower of Power who was a
monster and but but the outtakes of my
attempts to play the charts on whatever
song it was I was meant to play on
were saved and became this 29 second cut
on hoist called
Riker's mailbox is the name of the song
obviously
Riker he played Riker a Next Generation
Boom come on and it was my mailbox it
was my outtakes and it's and and Paul
God bless him gave me a cold wreck I got
a gold dragon I got a hoist gold record
on my wall framed God I used to I was I
was listening are you a fish guy I was
fish in college yeah before any of my
friends I can't spare a moment on the
dog face boy I won't lend another hand
to the warm girl of Hanoi don't deplete
my oxygen for the guy who's turning blue
but ask me and I'll do anything for you
remember that one beautiful oh well
let's go out to dinner and see a movie
that's the one I remember oh yeah yeah
they're great my forever friend Kent who
goes to every [__] fish concert he's
been 100 I'm like how do you go to
hundreds of concerts the deadheads used
to do I just can't believe you're like
10 years or more younger than me so
you're in an era I'm 50. yeah I'm 70. so
20 years younger wow so I look 60 is
what you're saying well you were talking
about the 70s 80s because I was thinking
about your influences were in the 80s if
my influences were in the 70s my
influence is really were the 70s too I
mean I I love I love the 70s my my dad
was a big hippie my mom kind of liked
the pop 70s stuff she loved Joni and
Carly Simon and you know she was doing
Valium and uh you know imaginary snow
angels in the carpet listening to that
[__] all [__] up and uh and my dad was
into Zeppelin and uh my dad brought home
the cream album from a student of his
not Charlie John Barleycorn that was in
Korean that was um this is uh yeah
Ginger maker the drummer yeah wow
Clapton and he liked all that [__] well
he was a jazz guy but uh he thought
maybe I'd like it and he was right
do you still go to concerts
when's the last time you went to a
concert what concert was it Paul Simon
and sting together at The Forum how
boring was that I thought that was great
I'm kidding I love both of them both of
them and then I remember sting saying
because they traded back and forth and
occasionally they'd uh you know they did
a song and a couple songs together and
come and sting said well I hope Paul
doesn't hear this and he told this great
story about when he was traveling in his
station wagon around the South has been
I guess a pre-police band that sting
might have been in the toured bars right
and he said uh we used to play this and
then sting sang we all came to look for
America and it was
wow that's cool he was just having a
good time it was great and this was a
tollywood bowl no this was at the Forum
at The Forum The Fabulous yeah
oh yeah I love the form I've seen some
concerts there I saw the Eagles there
and
um you know I'm I love that you play the
trombone I think it's just amazing um I
love that I'm across the street from my
only trombone I mean that's that's
probably my coolest credit is that I'm
on the Hoist album what do you mean what
do you look at all look at all the work
you've done no no but I'm saying in
terms of cool you don't think playing uh
you know all these Star Trek I think
these in directing Commander William
Riker and all that all this stuff that's
cool I think it's very cool right what
I'm saying
of the of the other part you know you
know what I mean when I say cool this is
the right
yeah like for me I I just came out with
a new album and uh my band's called Sun
spin and I thought it was really cool
that Richard Blade who's like the 80s
guy DJ he has first wave with Richard
Blade and this next band is a band
called sunspin and and he played and I
have it and I posted it but he played it
and talked about the band and loved it
and played it see and I thought that was
one of the coolest things I didn't know
you had a band yeah called sunspan yeah
I I look I always loved music and I was
like do play out live
um we we did before the pandemic and now
um we play Live virtual shows
and that's a lot is that live virtual
well we're live yeah and people are
watching us you play at the cons
um I you know I play sometimes I'll play
acoustically at like little round tables
and things and play for some people and
play some songs they love you in the
kind of circuit you're very well loved
you are so like I think it's important
how do you when you go to these cons do
you
um hey look people know that's why we're
here together yeah because we met on the
con we're not instantly loved you
exactly and I felt the same way I felt I
trusted you enough that I would get a
drive to your house to do a [__]
podcast which I never I I tried to get
out of it three times I said what don't
you zoom like or any other [__]
podcast where you think there's no
cameras then I find out there are
cameras it's got to be in person it's
just more I feel you I hear you yeah but
you dug in on it I had to well when I
like someone I'm like I gotta have them
as a guest and you know not all guests
are that open
um not all the guests are you know but
yeah but the list of the people that you
had when I rolled through some of I mean
they're all great they're all great but
I mean I checked in I told you I checked
on Nathan right I texted him this
morning and I checked it on WWE Will
Wheaton and they both said oh please say
hi to me so great he's so self-effacing
he's so prepared he so they both said
glowing [__] about that's awesome it
really is that's really nice
qualia mind
look I got a note from not only my
producer on this podcast who says been
taking these over the last few weeks and
have noticed increased Focus they're
easy to take and they don't wreck my
stomach
I agree wholeheartedly I have taken them
for here's what happened
I started taking these thinking I
ordered them and that they didn't send
me these that they were a sponsor I
swear to God I forgot qualia neuro
hacker was an actual sponsor because I
hadn't read a spot for him and I thought
oh you order these for your mind for
focus
and I've taken one every day for a
couple of months now and I'm telling you
I feel different I'm taking these it's
it's part of the I'm taking I I take my
antidepressants I take my vitamins but I
take qualia mind I take the neuro hacker
every day religiously because I do
notice Ryan that I am sharper don't you
notice I'm a little sharper lately I
have noticed yeah yeah I I say this in
the podcast and I have a feeling
call your mind huh our sponsor neuro
hacker combines 28 of some of the most
research-backed nootropic ingredients on
earth into an ultimate brain fuel
formula qualia mind and it's been
changing people's lives for years now
the formula is non-GMO vegan gluten free
and the ingredients are meant to
complement one another factoring in each
ingredient's effect on mental Clarity
look what's great about this it's backed
by a 100-day money-back guarantee so you
have almost three months to try neuro
hackers qualiamind at no Financial Risk
and decide for yourself that's how
confident they are
um
I really love this product I do and it
works for me I wish you could wake up
with me every day and see that I
actually take this and I would not stop
taking it
see one of the best brain fuel formulas
on Earth can do for your mindset go to
neurohacker.com IOU for a hundred
dollars off that's only thirty nine
dollars a bottle and as a listener of
inside of you use code IOU at checkout
for an extra 15 off your first purchase
that's neurohacker.com IOU to try neuro
hackers call your mind with code IOU to
experience life-changing performance
these statements have not been evaluated
by the Food and Drug Administration the
products and statements are not intended
to diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease this message is sponsored by
discover did you know you could reduce
the number of unwanted calls and emails
with online privacy protection the
latest Innovation from discover discover
will help regularly remove your personal
info like your name and address from 10
popular people search websites that
could sell your data and they'll do it
for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection by the way working
with Will did you know a lot of like the
stuff because he's obviously an open
book hence his books up there you know
did you know a lot of the things that
were going on personally in his life at
all he kept it from everybody well and
his parents were there and we thought it
was a copacetic family we thought
everything was hunky-dory that they were
just quiet
we had no idea until he started to go
through whatever he went through to find
he by the way is great at this have you
seen ready room yeah I saw you on there
yeah he's really really he's just so
well read and so like does the research
does knows what he's talking what you do
too he's also got what you he makes us
comfortable
he's also very present which he's which
is essential I think yeah in this job
and he really loves Star Trek he does he
told me those stories where he would go
in early and look at the ship and go in
there before he even started working and
all that were you was that a parent were
you like this kid just wow this kid's no
he didn't feel like a kid to us
I'll tell you this is a story that I
tell all the time but I'll share it with
you so that you can have it in your in
your table a repertoire repertoire
you've probably heard it already no when
he he grew up in the show obviously
right so he turned
started when he was 13 maybe so he
turned 16 he got a driver license and
enough money he bought a bought a Honda
Civic which was the same car that
Patrick drove at the time right wow so
we finished work together at uh we spent
at the same time when they were walking
out of the out of the sounds tape to go
to where our cars were parked and um
he's feeling he's full of himself right
he's 16 years old he's he's got a car
he's going to the parking garage he's
gonna drive his car home he just worked
on his team so uh we're walking back to
the garage she says you know Fricks
I could tell by the clothes that you
wear and the music comes out of your
dressing room
you used to be cool didn't you oh my God
you've never heard that story before
that's one of my big convention stories
he said that oh and I quote him and I
bust his balls for it every time what
did you say at the time did you laugh of
course I laughed like [__] you kid
exactly I think I laughed with a [__]
you kid but uh so he he's I I never let
him live it down he's amazing he's an
amazing human being he really is and I
just you know it's tragic it's like
hearing that story where he sent a
letter to his parents and and said
everything and they just didn't respond
and it just did you do you remember
reaching out to him at all saying hey if
I'm here if you need me no we said that
in how we behaved to him which is what
it makes him say to us that we were his
family he we treated him as an equal I
think in a way that he wasn't treated
maybe on some other
maybe at home right which we'd none of
us knew and I always think of myself as
a pretty good Observer of human behavior
we were all in the dark about it we've
and we've talked about it privately
behind us back and said did you [__]
know I didn't [__] know another idea
but he is so
eloquent about the relationship how
important that his relationship is with
us and we with him yeah he brings when
we're together in that rare time we get
to do a panel with everybody
he brings a level
of sincerity to the panel and it in form
he's so informed
that doesn't allow us to get sarcastic
or um
what's the word I'm looking for with you
um you've you've done the surface yeah
very serious he doesn't allow any of us
to go into that Pat kind of answer world
because he's sincere and he wants and he
listens and he's a very special man
that's amazing you know um I've heard a
lot of stories my friend Troy lives in
um up in Vancouver and I was asking him
some questions about what he knows about
you and he goes I just know that I've
heard that the cast
has always really gotten along that they
all for the most part really like each
other is that is that honestly true
absolutely true it is true and we've
both been on shows where that's not
right
I mean and still to get along we're
about to do all all this card right card
season three they're all coming back the
originals yes it's it's it's just I
giddy about it I I feel as excited as I
did when uh first Contact was opening it
feels like that big a deal to me and I
know it's not and I know I shouldn't get
excited but the buzz and the uh
you know it's not supposed to be a
reunion but clearly it is a reunion I
mean yeah and and it's
I talked to Brent today today's Brent's
birthday happy birthday Brent Spiner and
uh he said oh there's birdie levar's
shooting Hawaii uh NCIS why so Lavar was
calling from Hawaii said yeah take
birdie I'm going up to Sea uh Michael he
said oh I love him he's a nice this is
Brent so again the third party
Brent's a great guest you know uh I I
was thinking you know Sir Patrick right
who doesn't insist on being called Sir
unlike sir Ben Kingsley who does oh so
then I'll just say Patrick's too yeah
there we go so Patrick stew so so
Patrick do you feel like you must do it
I know now I want to sir when you have
Brent on
Brent does as good an impersonation of
Patrick as anybody in the world really
and I've never heard of an impression
really get him he'll do Patrick Stewart
talking to Serene McAllen
and their their accents are just
different enough that it's his it's like
Dana Carvey when Dana Carvey does
characters George Bush talking to the
church lady
Brent doing Patrick talking to Syria is
priceless oh you guys have to yeah start
uh tweeting Brent Spiner now that he has
to come on the podcast
um but how does I worry about you worry
about lines sometimes we we worry about
more now of course now as you get older
but then you look at a guy like Sir
Patrick Stewart who's 82 years old
you're directing episodes of Picard I
mean
a why is he why does he still want to do
this he has nothing to prove right B how
does he do it
those hours are excruciating and how
does he learn those lines right 82.
he does it because it's in his blood
he's been acting he's another one he's
been acting his whole life he got in the
world Shakespeare company was very very
young he's never stopped acting he's one
of the world's finest actors
he likes that he likes being that sure
and uh
you know what it's like well obviously
we maybe you may don't you don't feel
the same way the set is kind of our home
you don't you don't miss the set I do I
do miss the the feeling the the
interaction the connection with with
people and being creative and coming up
with things I do miss that
um no I absolutely do miss that yeah
anyway Patrick is
an early riser
he goes to bed having known as lines he
gets driven to work so he's working on
on the way in he gets made up and and uh
so we start early with Patrick and we
get Patrick's work done with any luck by
lunch or just a little out an hour or so
after lunch so we give him the producers
and the directors the first
half two-thirds of the day and then
somebody else will finish up so he
doesn't do it have to do 13 straight
anymore
however he insisted on doing EP Seasons
two and three of Picard which was 13
months straight so
did he have to convince the studio that
he was he could do this and he wants to
do this and he doesn't want to be they
went to him
well of course he asked him to do you
know they pitched him a show he said
here's what I want the show to be and
then
that's where Picard came from and how is
it directing him I mean you've done it
for a while now he's he's putty absolute
putty like he doesn't give you any grief
he doesn't give me any grief no he knows
if I'm coming to him I've either got an
idea that he inspired or that he may be
missed a moment that he may like to try
or
um or he'll say I know Tony
act better and I'll say yeah that would
be great or his other thing was is I
know how to fix this he's I know what
you mean Johnny think faster watch here
we go let's go
it would be that simple wow but he's um
we've done a lot together I'm a lot I
mean you've probably seen as how many
years have you been doing this since
since Next Generation 30 next generation
is 36 years ago 35 30. so of all the
movies you directed two of the movies
right they were big Blockbusters right
well they made 150 million dollars
I mean that's a big thing but you've
directed all these people many times
I have I mean do you ever have any
problems like does it ever get like a
family because we know families they
love each other and then they also go
well get with the [__] program why
isn't that well that could happen on the
set I and then I have to say it's you
know let's figure this [__] out right
but um I generally
of I'm not a big confrontation guy right
so
if if they're if they're dug in on
something I said you know by all means
do it you know especially with lines
that we there used to be such sticklers
when we did next gen you had to do it
by the book every every line no
consonants and and now
people have started people respect that
less which I think is a huge mistake
since the writers have been working on
these scripts for [__] months
sometimes years you got to give them the
respect to do them the way they're
written at least attempt to make that
come to life you can't change it
willy-nilly so the Kingsley that's
that's an issue I was trying to defend
the writers a little bit
but um
people misbehave sometimes because
they're tired because they're angry
about something at home well you know
yeah things happen things happen and and
and you try to compartmentalize it not
bring it to the set but [__] happens
[__] happens yeah and I'm pretty good
about trying to keep the keep it light
that's my Approach right I I've it's you
know the cliche is that we're not you
know we're not curing cancer we're
really just making a TV show let's
although it it appears that way when
you're working the intensity of like
what we're doing is so also what's the
most complicated way we could possibly
do this let's do it that way yeah it's
true we have to make it cool we have to
make people are going to lose their
attention we have to move the camera
more we can't it's none of that simple
[__] that I miss yeah you just put a
camera there
you think I think I think there's
gorgeous cinematography and especially
all the new Star Treks we're we're
encouraged to shoot sort of
cinematically and filmically and as
Robbie Duncan McNeil says you shoot the
thrill and but you got to get your story
and you got to get your close-ups and
you gotta see what as I say when let's
get in here and see what they're
thinking and that's that's kind of
sometimes not sometimes you want to know
what the [__] they're thinking you want
to know what they're feeling and if
you're zipping the camera around and
you're missing that sometimes and that's
uh
yeah do you ever have uh moments where
your your slamma Jamma right there in
the guys close up close-up it's just
right it's it's yeah choker chin to the
top of the eyebrows and it's there and
you want this moment and you just are
not getting it yeah and you just keep
and you feel bad but they're just you
got to learn when to cut
fish or cut bait or whatever the cliche
is yeah how many times what percentage
do you usually have to walk away going
that's not exactly what I wanted I don't
have to do it with any of those regulars
on that show it's the guest stars yeah
it's guest stars and you and if the
guest stars you don't know
if and then or or inexperienced actors
you think oh you're not there's no
getting there
or I just have been communicated it
clearly enough and I'm just embarrassing
everybody now by asking for another
taker trying to reform editing I know
how to fix this yeah cut on somebody
else and get somebody to do the loop the
line exactly done but um
as you experience is
as I said to David and Charlie Who David
ajala is who's the the male he's like
the male lead on Discovery he's
seniqua's partner and lover and uh I
said one time because it was a young
actor who just wanted to do this and
that I said to a challenge just off hand
off the side of my mouth I said God
experience could be a real burden so I
he and he loves that quote he brings it
up every time I might see a experience
as a bird
do you feel like when you direct do you
like let's say you jump into a show
that's already three seasons in two
seasons in five you don't have to watch
every episode of what the [__] going
on but you gotta get somebody to tell
you which ones you you should watch if
you're if you're going into so usually
the Creator will tell you yes somebody
the creative will tell you here's our
six best shows and this will give you
the tone and then the producing director
of the show will sit down with you and
say Here's how we do [__] here
like um Nathan's show that's right
Castle
um
Rob Bowman who was one of our favorite
directors on next gen was a producer
director on castle and he had me and he
said I think you'd be a good kind of a
big brother figure to to Nathan and I
know you worked with Stana because she
was in the librarian movies with Nate
with Noah so I knew the two leads and he
said I think he'd really be a good fit
for this company but
don't do any multi-move uh Dolly moves I
don't want to waste my time with that so
don't do anything clever where you come
under the elevator and bring them down
the hall and I don't need any of that
[__] and get me three sizes on the stars
in every scene those are the marching
orders couldn't be more clear right
you go to Falling Skies
which is this
do you work with him he I love Beaman
he's he's the one who tells this next
story beam is awesome Beeman and I wrote
a show sold a show together Beeman was
the showrunner on Smallville he wrote
directories yeah yeah he was the
producing director on falling side he's
awesome and he's got a big brain he's
got a big Breezy he's a kid he's a big
kid yeah he's a big kid but that was
that was a Spielberg produce show and
Beeman's uh approach when he sits down
with the directors coming to do and I
was doing that show because I I was a
friend of Noah and uh Noah was the
starter no Dolly no no that was uh
Falling Skies was it's meant to look
like
documentary war handheld footage yeah
yeah right so you follow everybody
around and you don't have to stay on
with the dialogue and go and see what
people say so you stay in a shot as long
as you can and the camera's on
somebody's shoulder and that's the way
the show looks totally different
but you have to know when you go I mean
you don't go into these shows and try to
[__] reinvent the wheel well I'm
gonna do Falling Skies on a crane I
think what I'll do is I'll say way back
here and then you don't get hired back
no you have to know like you said you
have to know the show right yeah because
the people who are going through
with their uh remote they want to
recognize oh there there's
NCIS or there's Star Trek or there's
Castle you know they want to recognize
their show and how much work does it
take when you get a directing gig on a
TV show
how much how much time do you have you
get the script and then you have a
couple of weeks yeah you gotta you got
the episode before yours you're in
actual prep with the production right
but hopefully you get a script before
that so you can start to break down the
Beats I break a script down as I did as
an actor you break the script down with
the Beats where you know each beat has
its own intention and all that [__] so I
still break down a script that way as as
a director so that
I don't miss a beat when I'm trying to
get shots and all that business or to
talk to the actors right so hopefully
you have a script but you know on
television you often start an episode
and the script isn't completely done I
mean it changes constantly it changes
constantly but you know sometimes you
have the ACT you're shooting and I mean
it's illegal now you can't start
allegedly with a without a full
production draft but it it used to
happen really they just keep writing it
as it went along wasn't that their way
on Smallville I mean sometimes but they
usually have the scripts the scripts
were pretty they were pretty solid but
they would change a little bit but you
never started an episode with um act one
and act three and an outline for the
other no I don't remember doing that
that would have been that would have
drove everyone crazy exactly and that
happens
it happened yeah it used to happen it
maybe didn't get to the floor like that
but you would some you would often start
prep oh sorry we don't have a full
production draft for you but come we're
gonna do a meeting with the production
designer we'll talk about what we think
the sets will be that you'd start your
meetings but just have like a five-page
document that said what they think the
episode's going to be
that's a bear that's yeah and just
imagine you you used to and you know
this you filmed on with film you're
shooting film and that's right I mean
how you you don't have a lot of you
I've done a show I did a show where the
episode that I prepped was scratched
either the day before we started
shooting yeah and Paul Geo who is my
writer on that he and I stayed up for 24
hours and he rewrote a script
and he talked me through it and by the
time we were ready to shoot we had a
brand new script
it must have been two days because we
had to cast it are you stressed
yeah Mike truco ended up being in a John
Delancey ended up being in it you know
all this you know all of our guys that's
stressful tractors as well oh my God
what about the script this is where you
call and say I think you're going to
play the devil in this are you cool I'm
Gonna Fly you up that's when you do what
um John punch did with me I got it
parked do you want to come I like that
you do yeah you don't I'm going to try
to wean you over I don't I don't know I
you know well don't get mad I didn't get
mad no I mean don't get mad when you
turn me down yeah it's not you let's
talk about Brent
who I've known and who I love for many
years
I have been told
by Dean Devlin who I work for all the
time who's a big fan of Brent's because
he shot an independence day which you
know Brent's great in
um Dean said I've tried to get Brent to
do the show I've offered it to him but
he's I said he said this is a great part
he says Frank's on one of the things I
was I was directing said
offered to Brent I said you want me to
call him he said yeah I said okay I'm
sure
I called Brent I said dude I got a part
to get starring part uh you're sort of a
Jeff Bezos kind of but you're kind of a
hippie you're a tech magnet and you've
got the women and you know you're
I said
where's it shooting I said well it's in
Glendale oh
so I'd have to drive from Malibu
I said dude it's
dollars and you get to hang it with me
all day we're gonna have a good time
I don't know Johnny
if offered to somebody else if they turn
it down I'll do it
this is my friend
with an offer
you're going to be that guy you are
clearly going to pull a prince I could
tell if you don't have to [__] lie to
me like Glendale it's actually pretty
close to me so I think it's like we're
going Glendale
um look you've had a lot of obviously a
lot of success a lot of fun you you're
doing what you love you've been married
to the same woman since what 88 88 been
with her longer than that that's 12 20
how many years is that 35 36 36 years
I mean you have stories that you could
go on forever about but I know that
you've also had some tough times
right I mean we all have I I lost a
sister a couple years ago you lost your
brother
um how do you is it something you know
sometimes they say it scars over but
it's always still there you always think
about it
um um how do you deal with that now
that's a really good question
um my brother who died of pancreatic
cancer at the age of 41.
um the week that my daughter was born
was uh as I said A friend of mine dear
friend we lived together in New York we
lived together in L.A we drove across
the country together when I came out
there so we were really thick as thieves
um since I'm involved in this thing with
Armin Sherman and kitty you know Kitty
swinkus who's armin's
quarkman's wife is Kitty who's a 19-year
pancreatic cancer survivor so she asked
me to get involved with this
organization called pan can I've never
had a charity that I really
believed in my heart I'm happy to help
people out and do it you know we work
for the food bank and I'll be a lot of
stuff and als's but this is my brother
so I got a story you know you have a
story with your uh as you as you try to
raise money
so being involved thanks to Kitty has
reminded me a lot of Daniel because I
talk about him more now like this this
wouldn't have come up I don't think had
a had not been a thing that I've been
talking about I like it I like thinking
of him I like talking about him fondly I
have great memories of the time
it would uh
which joint should we have which joint
this is the we had we had two bags apart
in the in the 1967 Chevy sport van and
the big decision was when we pulled over
because I like to fish at night so we'd
pull over some place but officially he'd
roll his eyes and he'd say
which part are we gonna smoke I said
okay you you decide I'm gonna fish
wow
I love it that's Daniel
I mean
um what had happened was it just
obviously shocked oh yeah but he was he
was yellow he had jaundice we took him
into the hospital for how long was from
the beginning he was sick till he lost
him oh not even six months five months
they opened them up that's about that's
the whole pancreatic cancer thing nobody
knows you got it they open them up
I guess they closed them up and looked
and said doctor said well there's
nothing we can do he's got six months to
live I mean he wasn't quite that cold
but those were the facts but you had no
idea until they called you like he was
that sick no idea
so who calls you
my mom and says Daniel's you know he's
got to go in the hospital so it we could
see it was really bad so Jeannie and I
flew out and then we got the bad news
together and then actually for part of
his last few months he came and hung
with house in our house in LA but he was
oh
and he had a daughter that he didn't
want to see because he was embarrassed
that he was sick and also he had been
divorced from the same woman twice and
he's he was a very complicated gosh how
did you lose your sister
well it was my dad remarried and they
had a child little Leah May who I have
her tattoos in my arm and she was born
with a chromosomal defect so
um she was always in hospitals always
right you know back and forth for a
while and then that's where she lived
but she was she couldn't really talk
she kind of laid there and she you know
they thought that she was going to pass
away right away when she was an infant
they said most of these children pass
away early it never and she was like one
of the longest cases she lived to like
14 15 years old and in that condition
in that condition
and just I mean probably almost died 30
40 times right and you know my dad was
not an emotional person was never I
would never not you know wasn't
affectionate wasn't I never saw any of
that ever it was just like go do the you
know it was just you know very hard very
old school and whatever
but when I called him and he and she had
passed I've never heard someone cry like
that it was jarring it was absolutely
jarring and you know people don't know
so it has been held up for 14 years that
that's you hit the nail in the head and
a lot of people they don't know what
it's like to lose a child most people
but that's as close as I will come to
knowing what it might feel like by
hearing my father how did your parents
were that something well they didn't
talk about a father who we spoke about
earlier my father never recovered my mom
and I mourned my mom and I wept my mom
and I excuse me I think dealt with it
very well
or as well as you can or as
realistically as you can my dad
my mom and I said for many years my mom
lived at me like 94 my dad died when he
was like 77. so she lived a long time
after him and um
we're both convinced that because he was
so damaged by Daniel dying and it's so
unnatural for you know yeah it he had
Alzheimer's he had really bad
Alzheimer's which may or may not have
been
connected it could be triggered
absolutely
yeah and then you talked briefly when
we're making coffee in the other room
you were saying how hard it is
to you know to watch him slowly Decay
you know with Alzheimer's the
Alzheimer's brutal because I watched my
grandfather Yeah it's brutal it's just
like and like you're and sweet Paul who
I spoke about earlier this producer had
early on saying all the time right and
he just died and he was
he was your age or a little he's in his
50s so it was really yeah for years and
my grandfather was brilliant well a lot
of them that's the other thing my cat
was brilliant a lot of people with
Alzheimer's are big brains
so maybe maybe I'll get lucky yeah
because I don't both of us should be
fine
we should be okay at least for that one
hey were you ever were you ever fully
yourself at all was there ever a time
you're like I'm Jonathan Fritz I'm a
good looking strapping Tall movie star
director and you got you were caught up
in your own [__] and you had to get
through that
um
on the set last week
I I've been walking back and forth
there was really strict uh security at
this uh Biltmore Hotel because it's a
museum it's got mosaics and gogan's and
it's a Vanderbilt Estate and all this
[__] but when I was called it a set we
go up a ramp and I had my little acting
bag with me and I had my suit on and for
days I just been walking back and forth
into this hotel past this security guard
so one day
he says I got to look in that bag and I
thought he was [__] with me so I said
oh dropped it back
and he did not find me funny at all and
I was with this PA who who I've been
entertaining by being an [__] I'm
like you you know I would like to
entertain oh yeah you know okay here
comes I gotta get along I Gotta Laugh
this guy wasn't having that so he said
who's your boss
so [__] move number two I said well I
guess you are
sit out on that bench
so it was clear
it was so clear that my [__] was not
funny and this guy was dead serious and
he wanted to look at my bag
and uh so I opened my bag and look I
said what are you looking for he said
well we're looking for guns and Away in
and people steal stuff on the way out
and I felt my mom and dad and and my
guilt of being a uh whatever you just
asked about and a privileged right right
it all came storming down on me and I
looked at it and it's this security
guard in the eye said I really didn't
mean to be that rude I am really really
sorry and I was I was so complicit and
it was so uh you know because I I'm sure
you've gotten in trouble to it sometimes
you just think you're funny and you're
just not [__] funny and people think
you're just an [__] yeah this was
that moment and the girl who was the PA
was there laughing because she thought I
was doing my [__] that I was or part of
whatever my stick is and this guy was he
was offended I had insulted him I you
know I was undermining his job and I in
the moment I turned and I looked for him
for days afterwards and that same thing
to test to apologize again and again wow
because it was I was so [__] guilty
of being an arrogant [__] so yes the
answer is yes and I've I've done it on
and off my whole life I think it's
inherent I don't think it's really an
[__] I think it's one of these things
where we sometimes maybe inadvertently
subconsciously go like ah you know
you've done this for so long the Swagger
and I'm actor and I'm funny and I make
people happy and I'm just like a good
guy and I and I'm just gonna my [__]
don't stink and here we go and uh Hey
and most the time it's funny and it's
good and you're being nice to people and
sometimes it's belittling or it could
come off you couldn't be more right and
it's inadvertent I mean you'd hope it
would be you have yeah I feel it from
you it's exactly because we don't mean
harm no and and we roll that's how we
roll I hate when it's like that one
person in the room they always say if a
hundred people are laughing at your 99
people are laughing and the one person
in the back thinks you're an [__] you
focus on that person I know it's like
bad reviews yeah it's bad reviews it's
uh I I we have empathy
um this is called [__] talking
with Jonathan Frakes these are my top
tier patrons they get to ask questions
they're amazing they support the podcast
go to patreon.com inside of you I love
you guys Nancy D well we love seeing you
in front of the camera you're getting
quite a glowing reputation as a director
what was the most challenging aspect of
first going behind the monitors oh
trying to make the schedule of the
amount of screwing around that the cast
on next gen including me is famous for
laughing between takes taking the piss
out of each other constantly because you
know the Star Trek was serious and talk
strike was generally very so when when
we were when we cut
who was wrestling it was singing there
was all kinds of [__] Patrick and dwarf
Dorne used to wrestle what and Brent
would do do uh like you were on Vegas
and he'd do a pretend Mike court and and
we were so bad that um especially in the
third or fourth or fifth season
the only time we would shut up was not
um
roll sound have speed camera none we're
still yeah you have to yell
action
number one
we we went right up until the end of
action and it drove [__] directors
crazy and then when I was directing I
thought
I get it and also early on you have to
prove yourself yeah yeah you were trying
to prove yourself I was very lucky
though I had I had a data show so I had
Brent Spyder was the he was the lead for
the weekend he's very reliable
uh Renee ashaveria wrote the episode as
a spec script who's now a big show
runner from also asked from Castle and
um I'd been shadowing for almost three
years right I was really you were I
thought I was ready uh Dave P how do you
feel about the way Star Trek has gone
with its latest shows I mean the the
next next generation or the the news
right I think they're uh
individually
exactly what uh rodberry would be
thrilled to see
and they have they're all they both have
all three of them have separate tones
what's really captured the audience I
think is this strange new worlds which
is
with Anson Mound and Ethan he's a good
buddy of mine we did a little Indie
together and uh he did an episode of
Smallville and yeah we did a whole
season on Discovery right so so that was
sort of the pilot was that season for so
those two shows are very important me
and Picard is as you probably know
season three we're all back together so
I have I have a very
affectionate and appreciative and
blessed feeling for all of the new when
do you when do you shoot that when
you're all together
that's done that's done that's air
that's air it airs wins February 16 we
dropped the first episode we're doing a
Premiere man's Chinese can I come yes
you can come
where do you want to be
what do you mean you want to go to the
premiere
I mean I could put you on the list put
me on the list if I'm in town hall I
will go really are you a tricky I mean I
know Star Trek I I watched The Originals
definitely a lot of The Originals and I
watched a lot of generations now you
weren't even born Deep Space Nine I
remember
um I watched some uh the movies I
watched all the movies definitely more
of a
Star Wars fan
but Star Wars and Star Trek
there's way the room for both Sarah G
yes Riker's my favorite next Generation
character hands down thank you good sir
for joining if you could be in any other
character on Star Trek besides Riker who
would you be and why data the Android is
my favorite character on the show
and what Brent does with it and not only
data he plays data lore song who created
data Alton song who's the grandfather of
the other so he's played five or six
variations on this character I'm uh he's
a he's amazing character played by an
amazing actor absolutely and we're
recording this on his birthday I love
that yeah
um by the way if I if you were new to
Star Trek if people are listening to you
and they go you know I don't really know
Jonathan Frakes I don't watch all the
Star Trek stuff I don't but you know
they watch Castle there's so many other
things you've done that they could go
and watch but if they were to start Star
Trek next Generation what episodes jump
out that you should see here's where you
if you have if you don't have time to
watch 182 hours of television
start with Best of Both Worlds part one
which is at the end of season three
and then it's a cliffhanger and then
Best of Both Worlds part two is the
beginning of season four and it's it's
as good as it gets for next gen I think
awesome a good answer right good answer
succinct no one's asked you that have
they never really it's a liar my appear
is there a storyline you wish had taken
place on the Star Trek series and if so
what is it oh God
it's just a question you don't answer it
I mean you know they probably explored
most stories yeah maybe up uh I love the
uh the Holodeck when uh I got to play
the trombone but they brought the
trombone in which was great
I think there was an opportunity for
more music probably oh yeah why didn't
Picard ever have an affair with what's
her name
which one uh wil Wheaton's uh mother
well maybe he did
hmm
do you think that's the subtext there
yes don't you I hope so I don't think
you would have asked the question if you
didn't suspect Maybe
Charlene see last question what was it
like filming North and South with
Patrick Swayze it was filmed a few hours
for me in Charleston what do you
remember about him well that's what I
fell in love with my wife Jeannie
Francis who played
Patrick Swayze's sister
Swayze was
he was the mayor of Charleston by the
way when we were down there it was a it
was the 80s need I say anymore
he was Patrick Swayze
and
I loved him he had a huge heart
very talented great Horseman
great man
um and he carried that I mean he was he
was a good movie star yeah you know what
happened to him
he died from pancreatic cancer
pancreatic cancer where can people go if
they want a pancan.org pancan.org
there's support there there's a it's a
it's one of the biggest Killers well
it's not like that it's the survival
rate associating when my brother died
was a three percent survival rate now
it's up to 12 which is a big deal so
easy was awesome Charleston was awesome
I remember taking my wife on my wife
Jeannie asking Genie out on a date and
we went to 82 Queen Street and with the
in the in the cast where uh Kirsty alley
was in the cast and she was like the the
uh the gang leader right you know that
we'd all hang out together and go out
dancing and all that stuff and I said to
Christian I really think I like Gigi and
she's saying it's okay freaks I think
Genie likes you I think you should ask
her out she was like we go to the to the
counselor for for advice
it was a riot you remember that like
it's yesterday oh I also remember David
Carradine was also in the show David
Carradine and Patrick Swayze were on the
23rd floor of the hotel we were staying
in
and that was where the bar was and I
don't know what they were what they had
had but
there were big shutters it was South
there were big Shutters on the Windows
of this of this uh lounge or whatever it
was in the hotel and Swayze said
I Can Fly
and carried said [__] you I could fly so
they both ran towards the windows and we
had to tackle them both
oh my God you know what a true story I
have an animator sometimes that will
animate clips of this podcast and I
think that right I might have Swayze
crazy
[__] you I could fly
this is amazing will you come back I
will come back this has been a joy I I
could talk to you forever it's so easy
thank you for making the house thank you
very much thank you
[Music]
guys thanks for listening I appreciate
you uh we're gonna give a shout to our
top tier patrons now those are the folks
who give back to the show in more ways
than one they keep the show going
patreon.com inside of you uh please help
the show if you can and if not just
listen to it and subscribe and tell
everybody about it
um if you missed the intro you might
want to listen to some a lot of good
information there I don't need to repeat
it do I Ryan
unless you want to I mean if people
liked it uh you know people like hearing
you talking you you could read the phone
book and people I don't think that's
true I think people get annoyed
you want to try
um let's see uh all I mentioned was that
uh the inside of you online store has
great merch like lexma scripts and a
bunch of stuff go to sunspin.com for
band merch or album just came out
streaming everywhere
um
patreon.com inside of you to be a patron
and um talk about podcast
um
you know check it out
you know we're doing that there's
Wednesday we air Tuesday with a little
episode a little uh podcast that could
and uh we couldn't do without you write
a review I hope you liked today's
episode let's give let's give the shout
outs
these are the top tiers folks we're
gonna do it
um
all right you throw out a dialect I'll
see if I can do it it might be dialect
uh it might be bad
Southern
little Lisa Yukiko GLE Brian H Nico P
Robert B English British Jason w
Sophie m
Kristen K Raj C Joshua D
Jennifer Wren Stacy L Jamal F or go New
Zealand because they were heading that
direction can we go Australian maybe
sure
Jennifer Lopez Janelle B Mikey Eldon
suprema
and 99 more
Santiago m
chair W lien P Janina
mayapi
Belinda Belinda in Dave H Sheila G Brad
D chairman
um Ray h
let's see the instructions
Liliana a Talia M Betsy D Chad B Den in
Angel M Rhiannon C
Minnesota
Corey K I have no idea they have Nixon
Michelle a Jeremy C brandy brandy D I
don't I don't know Boston
Becky cat and have it yeah give me a
list
snip snedic Joanne
no New York it's like it's like Boston
pocket guy Eugene and Leah I can't do it
sorry did they do New York then New York
Eugene and Leah Corey Heather L
uh Jake B
what is it Angela F Mel s Orlando C
Caroline R Christina Sarah Gage Sheena
Emma R Andrew M zaroichi 77 andreasen
Swedish
oh yeah
Oracle
Karina in I don't do it Swedish
feeding Amanda r i Irish
Kevin e
Stephanie k
Jarel billies Jim and Jay Leon and Jay
Luna r
Cindy e Mike f
Scottish Stone Age Brian L KTB Aaron air
R Kendall house J meredithai
Charlene C I don't know if Connor listen
back for verification oh he's Irish
right for the Irish Irish part but uh
guys I can't uh say thanks enough for uh
tuning in I love you keep listening um
you know we keep doing it we'll just
keep doing it as long as you love keep
doing it and keep supporting me so I
thank you it was great to see all all
the patrons in Dallas I hope to see you
guys in Atlanta we'll be there in March
fourth and fifth we're doing a
Smallville nights being Welling on
Saturday night it's Creation
Entertainment in Atlanta so hopefully
we'll see you there all right uh from
myself Michael Roosevelt in the
Hollywood Hills of California
I'm Ryan taze I'm here too can you use
you know you used to do that right in
this no you used to go on I guess the
way you said oh uh for the Hollywood
Hills of California I'm Brian Taylor
yeah Hollywood Hills of California we
love you guys thanks for listening I
appreciate you Dental town all right
be good yourself
[Music]